make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering war of realms
part four like we're finally getting
back in the war realm spent like three
weeks since we carry part three
okay so war realms those you guys who
were kind of playing catch-up here warp
realms is a story where basically earth
is like the last stand for like all the
Asgardians released what's left of the
Asgardians really all the other nine
realms right I mean that's what we kind
of talked about like the last three
videos right there like yep Malekith the
accursed who's basically this dark elf
this evil dark elf dark elf who's been
caught like conquering all the other
realms that exist out there so like
muscle hime the realm of Surtur which is
currently being ruled by his daughter
cinder as well as like the fall of
Asgard which it's kind of ironic because
Malekith didn't really have to do
anything all he had to do was unleash
like man God right like this force of of
evil that just horrifies everybody who
has to fight it and really like this
immutable and indestructible force onto
Asgard and then in turn just kind of
conquered everything but at this point
in time you kind of have the groups that
have sort of split off right and this
story actually picks up or really
focuses largely on not really Freya but
the team that was I guess really The
Secret Avengers a team that was designed
to face off against um well not really
The Secret Avengers but the team that
was designed to face off and essentially
like take out the black Bifrost now
remember when it comes to Marvel comics
and it comes to the Bifrost it's
essentially a wormhole I mean it's a
wormhole by different names but it's a
wormhole I mean it does create a
physical bridge that you can use to like
teleport yourself to another realm but
there has to be a an access point on the
other sock oh no it's kind of a hard
example to describe but the basis behind
this is that you can't has to be a
two-way door right so like you have a
door on one side where Asgard is which
is usually where the Bifrost is located
at and then you have a door on the other
side which could be like the main Marvel
Universe like earth which is called
Midgard or like Jotunheim where the
frost giants are or or the realm of the
realm of like Nadav earlier where the
dwarves dwell and they build weapons and
things like that
um yet have that on the other side and
where the Bifrost and Asgard was
destroyed Malekith actually built his
own black Bifrost which allowed his
forces to enter into the other realms
and that's how he's been getting around
so fast
it was one of the things that was that
was kind of thrown out to us and it
really kind of made sense the more we
thought about it but at the same time
we've also got like the rescue of Thor
we talked about that in the previous
video where Thor had basically been
tricked and whisked away to the frost
giants where he was just kind of
destined to fight for presumably until
he exhausted against what was basically
a battle of attrition
my ledges and almost endless number of
frost giants and then by the time he was
located by The Secret Avengers uh he was
in like a his his berserker rage right
that's one of these we talked about with
Thor his Thor has a berserker rage that
doesn't really come out all that often
but it will if Thor's engages in a
battle and becomes blood lusted and it
lasts long enough right because that's
kind of the stages of Thor you have like
baseline Thor that we know of right the
one who's just kind of like let's go
fight some enemy or something like that
but if he goes until like a fierce
battle and he's fighting for his life
and then that goes on long enough he'll
almost kind of go into a feral State and
then go into a berserker rage much like
what will rain does where he doesn't
really recognize anybody he knows he
just attacks everything he sees now the
benefit to that is it amps up Thor to
like an extreme degree the downside of
that is he could attack you as well
that's kind of a danger of like The
Secret Avengers showing up there and
having to rescue him and like talk him
down it is literally like okay man so
like he could kill us all so we kind of
have to be on our guard now of course
all this leads to The Secret Avengers
retreating back to Avengers Mountain
which of course is located in the body
of a dead celestial and this is kind of
an important thing here because what
Jason even does is almost kind of defy
conventional wisdom a celestial for the
most part they wore actual beams at one
point in time but by whatever manner and
whatever means which has never really
been fully explored they basically kind
of evolved past a baseline mortal form
and kind of became beings of pure energy
and when that happened they kind of
maintained these shells almost like what
Galactus has the sort of regulates their
energy but they can be defeated when
they're destroyed they end up going to
what's basically this bar that's
occupied by a being called the fulcrum
now a lot of that was covered in Neil
Gaiman's Eternals but the fulcrum is
maybe the one above all maybe it's not
we're never really given a definitive
answer and we never have and we may
never get one but Celestials can be
killed and so with this celestial being
dead what Jason Aaron again is kind of
defined conventional wisdom by saying
there's still energy within this
celestial which really shouldn't be that
way so it means one of two things either
he's totally changing the mythos on what
happens to Celestials when they die or
this Celestials not dead as it was it's
kind of cool you know to see that see
this sort of scenario play out but of
course it isn't being sharee
who basically like uses the power of the
celestial to destroy a whole bunch of
the forces of the of the frost giants
and the forces of cinder from Muspelheim
and and so on but it's a huge amount of
energy being let off now of course while
that's going on you have Freya who's
basically using like the black sword
and crushing all these enemies which is
kind of par for the course but the big
thing that comes out of this is Odin
makes his return now
Odin has arisen from the odinsleep but
he's done it prematurely that's a very
important thing for us to understand
here and the reason why is that when
Odin kneel because of the vast amount of
power he possesses letting all that
energy off using all that energy really
requires him to basically rest his
mortal form right never leaves mortal
form but to rest his physical form and I
guess it is mortal insofar as he can die
but to basically rest his essence right
like to basically sit down and
rejuvenate and recuperate which is
called the Odin sleep but because of the
huge amount of power he possesses the
more of that power he uses the longer he
has to recharge right so it's like
rechargeable batteries if you if you
take a take a rechargeable rechargeable
battery off and you use you know you use
it for like five or six minutes and then
you put it back on it'll take less time
to charge then if you totally used the
entire battery it'll take more time to
recharge that's how Odin works now the
massive amount of power he possesses the
odinforce he uses is huge in scale
though because of the fact that he used
a huge amount of it to try to face off
against man gog and was ultimately
unsuccessful what this means is that
when he kind of reawakened he's not
fully charged and so this is not Odin at
100% power if Odin was at 100% power
this war will be over like that because
Odin's just that powerful he's just that
capable I mean the forces that are at
play here are dwarfed by the power of
Odin and that's consistently happened
across the board right I mean with the
exception of like of like Serdar in his
home realm and sometimes outside of
Asgard depending on the case but the
fact that Odin was able to imprison him
really indicates Odin overpowers him the
forces of like Malekith things like that
but more often than not Odin it like 100
percent full strength facing off against
a foe can usually defeat most of them of
course again there's a few here and
there that he can't beat super-powerful
cosmic entities different things like
that but in this scenario he'd be able
to overpower them but being in a
weakened state of course he wants to
know where is my wife uh what's going on
with Freya because he's kind of been
over here in these little tidbits of a
conversation and the little tip is a
conversation he's been hearing is
basically that like Freya is still on
Sparta hime and she's basically trying
to protect the Dark Bifrost of Malekith
now with that being the case what this
means is that with a huge amount of
power at their disposal all these Aaron
forces facing off against her while the
power the black sword does amplify what
what Freya can do and it makes her
really really capable she can still
exhaust as she can still be tired and so
that's basically what will happen
again it's a war of attrition the forces
keep coming and coming and coming and
eventually she'll just wear out and then
she'll end up falling and that's really
the fear of Odin is that his wife will
die because she doesn't have the
odinforce she cannot fight for for an
extended period of time she can fight
about as long as any Asgardian can and
probably a little bit less than most
because she's not really battle-hardened
and while she is older that does take a
physical toll on her body and so again
like it's kind of a funny thing because
what is up happening is in the midst of
all this Tony Stark basically chimes in
remember he's back alive now that's
covered in dance lots I am an run where
he basically cloned his body and then
put his essence put his mind into it and
then came back right we've seen him do
that a couple times before so it's not
really a new thing that Dan Slott
thought up but what he does is he sits
down and says okay look so like we kind
of knew that you were gonna make a
return somewhere along the line it was
only a matter of win and so what we did
is we started making preparations what
we've done is built you a suit that will
serve the purpose of allowing you to
like go into battle despite the fact
that you may not be fully recharged
right because there have been times in
Marvel Comics where Odin hesitate has
undertaken the odinsleep and he's been
in the Odin sleep for years right like
just four years I mean not like 20 30 40
years but like two three or four years
he's been asleep for a long time and so
with that being the case it was kind of
like we don't know exactly when he's
gonna return but we do know that when he
does return he probably won't be at 100%
power now again while all that happens
you kind of have Freya who again
basically Falls and that's because
Malekith has shown up in far and fartole
hime now the way this works in Marvel
Comics is something I want to talk about
for a second the way it works in Marvel
Comics is you have various beings or
entities or deities or whatever they're
defined as like Dormammu or Mephisto or
Sid Iraq who gives a juggernaut as power
you have these various beings that have
work auld home dimensions and what that
means is that as so long as they're in
that home dimension they're at peak
strength and so Malekith isn't really
like Mephisto right like the longer
Mephisto the devil basically of Marvel
Comics the longer he stays away from his
home dimension the weaker he gets with
Malekith it's not really that way but in
his home dimension he usually is more
powerful than he is if he's outside of
his home dimension now again he's still
a force to be reckoned with outside of
Sparta hime
but here in Sparta hime he's pretty
strong not only that he's cunning and
he's battle-hardened and so showing up
here and with Freya wielding her sword
she's not really experienced she's she's
not forth and so when this happens like
she's taken out by Malekith pretty
quickly he literally throws like a spear
through her
and essentially takes her out and where
he intends to kill her suddenly we end
up having Odin who shows up with his
Iron Man armor now this is kind of a
cool thing but it also doesn't come out
of nowhere and that's one of the funny
things about this is that you know kind
of the the iron all-father is really
what is called you know like Odin gets
Iron Man armor essentially when it comes
to Tony Stark um for the most part with
his Iron Man armors that he's developed
over the years they've largely been
confined to himself right I mean she's
usually kind of been like okay I needed
a suit of armor to achieve a particular
goal right like I need to sneak into
someplace and I can't be detected so I'm
gonna build myself a suit of armor that
can basically camouflage it can for all
the tens of purposes refract light and
become invisible and then it's things
like I need to be able to travel through
space so I need a suit of armor that
will let me travel through space and
depending on where I need to go
sometimes achieve speeds that are not
necessarily faster than light but are
exceedingly fast right so if weight was
part of the guardians of the galaxy then
there's like the classic Iron Man armor
where he just fights on earth and and
it's pretty straightforward but we've
also seen instances where he's built
suits of armor for other beams out there
but for people that are beyond his own
out beyond himself we seen him do it
with Thor we've seen him blend a Thor
armor I'm sorry uh strd and technology
with his own and they create like
weapons as it was only a matter of time
before something like this happened and
I have to admit the suit of Odin
actually looks pretty badass like it
looks pretty beast
it's even got like built-in eyepatch
where like it just covers one of his
eyes it's kind of cool I think it would
have been like really Tony Stark like it
would have been so Sparky if like Tony
Stark came along and was like I gave it
two eyes and it's like but why I could
only use one like I don't know I just
kind of feel like you should have two
eyes yeah I think it would've been funny
there's just one either that he can't
use I don't know make wouldn't believe
that he has two eyes again yeah like I
don't know but him showing up here what
it does is it basically like main lines
in channels the odinforce and so it's a
suit of armor built by Iron Man this
designed to regulate and channel the
power of the odinforce
for Odin himself now likely he will keep
this armor and that's kind of the cool
thing is we can see him use it in the
future and that's why stories like this
are so cool is because these small
little tidbits get thrown in that will
likely play a bigger role later on down
the launch but again like in this this
particular conflict where him and Freya
start facing off against each other
they're ready to die and that's kind of
an important thing here right because
for an Asgardian at least it has
Guardian warrior
greatest death they can achieve is to
die an honorable battle that's why
Valhalla is such a huge mythos and in in
Marvel Comics when it comes to like Thor
dying and things like that joining my
brothers in the afterlife you know and
telling tales of my great exploits and
Wars and getting drunk and having lots
of sex and eating amazing food like that
kind of stuff is is really like what as
Guardians look forward to and so that's
one of the things you notice here is
they actually kind of welcomed this
death as that's why it's interesting
because in this moment the black Bifrost
is totally destroyed which means that
Odin and Freya appear to have been lost
in it all like they're basically dead
and then you have like all the forces of
Malekith that have been cut off now what
you also have here is the Punisher and
you've got the forces of like what's
left of Asgard in the Avengers Mountain
and and Punisher is like so these are
called guns and like they're very good
because they help you get rid of bad
guys just point and pull this trigger
The Punisher is educating as Guardians
on the use of guns and I'm gonna be
honest if ever there were anybody to do
it he would be the Punisher this guy
knows how to use it all it is kind of
cool to see that that little bit of a
moment a little bit of a discussion
between these guys but then you sort of
have you have Jane Foster who pipes up
remember she was made the new all mother
when Freya left to join the mission to
take out the black 5 Frost and so she is
for all intents and purposes the leader
of the Asgardians right because Thor was
gone at that point there was nobody left
to lead the Asgardians up like Odin was
in the odinsleep so he obviously
couldn't couldn't partake in the whole
battle Loki is basically dead Thor was
you know cast out and in banished to
Jotunheim and Freya herself had to leave
and Heimdall incapacitated and so
they're all really there were really
like no as Guardians left but Jane
Foster has also been Thor and so like
she was the best person to pick for this
role and so it's kind of a funny thing
because in this moment what is up
happening is where she steps up and says
like somebody has to lead this battle
the forces of malakut are essentially
cut off you can't bring any more forces
to Midgard it's now our chance to turn
this hide in to win the war then you
have Odin's son who steps up and says no
if anybody is going to leave this it's
going to be me it's gonna be like the
the son of Odin which makes sense
because like Thor's the battle-hardened
guy Thor is the experienced guy and
that's why I kind of like it because
they both get their time to shine right
I mean I've said it a million times
before
I love Jane Foster Thor she was awesome
you know and for all the naysayers
whatever but like I love the idea of
Jane Foster Thor and so having oh I'm
sorry having like Odin's son step up and
say hey look none enough I'm going to
lead this battle because this is a war
of Asgard's forces therefore like as the
like a true Asgardian should be the one
to leave that lead this it's kind of
cool because it's basically Jason Aaron
at least it seems like Jason Aaron
saying hey like Thor is a character that
everybody looks so it looks to when it
comes to like leading a war of
Asgardians and really Earth's forces
against anybody else do I think Jane
Foster could have done it absolutely but
it makes sense that you would bring like
Odin's son in like Thor the last guy
because that was the prophecies it was
made as a beginning of the story right
like Odin son is the only one who can
really win this war he's the only one
who can pull it off that was a last you
know little tidbit of advice that was
given by Loki before he died and so like
bringing Thor back and bringing him in
makes the most sense but I love war from
so far like I'm digging war from this
story is amazing like I love it and I
love own ins like iron man armor it
looks awesome and I really hope we get
to keep it like I really hope it stays
around though with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]